لا يمل الاحتلال من صناعه الموت ولا تكاد
جباليه تكفكف جراح مجزره حتى تف جاها اخرى
اشد عنفا وجنونا يرى بعض المتابعين لحرب
نتنياهو على غزه ان ما يجري ليس قتالا بل
قتل رخيص من الجو فال العسكريون يمطرون
الاحياء المليئه بالحياه والاحلام
والاطفال دون سبب عسكري الا التشفي
والانتقام حسب ما
يقولون ضين على الجمر في غزه لا ينحنون
ولا يرفعون الرايه البيضاء رغم الالم
اللهم اجرنا في
م حكايه غزه متجدده يهبط صاروخ على هذه
العائله فيستشهد احمد ذو العامين وشقيقته
عائشه ذات الاسبوعين تكفكف الجده دموع
الاباء ويغادر الصغيران هذا العالم غير
الماسوف عليه دون ان يفهم شيئا عن كل ما
يجر ارسل الصاروخ لم يفهم شيئا ايضا عن اي
جبابره يحاول ان يكسر انا بس بدي اوجه
رساله لنتنياهو بدي اقول له اولادي كلهم
في ذا الوطن اولادي كلهم في ذا فلسطين
وانا اولهم هو مفكر لما انه يتشطر على
اطفال هدول بده يعمل شيء هو هيك نجح مثلا
حقق اللي بده اياه ما حقق اللي بده اياه
خلص و اقول لك على شغله انا ما بدي شي من
العرب في مثل عننا شو بقول ما حق جلدك غير
ضفرك واحنا القدس لنا مش لحدا واحن اللي
بدنا
نحررها يدخل العدوان يومه
ال5 لكن ما اراده الاحتلال هجوما سريعا
يقضي على المقاومه غدا شيئا اخر فدوي
صفارات الانذار يقلق سماء تلبيب وملايين
الاسرائيليين يبحثون عن ملاجئ حسب بيان
جيش
الاحتلال اللهم سدد الله اكبر اما
المقاومه فما زالت تخرج على المحتلين من
تحت ركام صنعوه وتترسم عند كل زاويه
هدموها لتعيد عشرات منهم كل يوم الى
القبور والمشافي داخل
اسرائيل وسط كل هذا الدم والدموع ينقسم
العالم الى متامرين مع المحتلين
ومتفهمين وعاجزين في مشهد ذكر العالم بانه
ما زال ماس الرحم بعالم الغاب حيث ياكل
القوي الضعيف لم تجد الولايات المتحده ما
يزعجها من كل ما يجري غير جهد المقل الاتي
من اليمن فها هي تحزب الاحزاب لتهديد
الحوثيين حتى يوقفوا مضايقات للسفن
المتجهه الى موانئ الاحتلال لكن جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين مصممه على ان لا طريق
لاي سفينه الى موانئ الاحتلال الا اذا دخل
الغذاء والدواء الى المحاصرين في غزه يجب
ان يتحرك الضغط على اسرائيل لايقاف
عدوانها وفك حصارها على قطاع غزه والدول
الاخرى الموجوده في المنطقه يجب ان تتجه
الاتجاه الصحيح بالضغط على اسرائيل
وامريكا لايقاف هذا الصلب هل وصل الحال ان
تدلل اسرائيل الى هذا المستوى بانه اي طرف
يقوم بمواجهه عدوانها وصفها يواجه هو يعني
المطلوب من اليمن ان توقف عن مضايقه
اسرائيل كي نسمح لها بالاستمرار بقتل
فلسطين وبقتل ابنائها وتدميرها وقتل
اطفالها
ونسائها منذ بدايه العدوان وحلفاء
الاحتلال يحذرون من اتساع الحرب وخروجها
عن غزه المحاصره لكن مراقبين يرون ان ما
يجري في غزه لن يظل فيها دوما وان دخول
الحوثيين قد يكون مجرد بدايه لطوفان
ات